hello we are more point the team
representative of colombia our two
cristian roger developers and our
designer jesus my name is andrea i am
the project manager our business
our platform is basically unite
small and small businesses and
entrepreneurs who have needs with
specialists who know how to do those
tasks that they need the idea is
what income to the platform you
you sign up through the platform and
you publish your need I need
I am a small company I am a
cafeteria that needs a plan
marketing I put online I need a plan
of marketing and a bidder that is a
specialist who was doing those
tasks that you do not know how to do I'm going to
tell me the jolla be done through
an auction method in reverse
then you are going to place what you need
when you need it and at what price
you need and he's going to bid you and tell you
I can do it, we can do it in
so long and at such a price once you
you have different offers you are going to
choose a match
that's why more coin and the idea is that that
person you charge a price to make
that one
labor and we charge a percentage
of the transaction is the way in which
it puts me fixed in our business